Hi, and thank you for coming to my talk.
Let's get started.
As you can tell from my outfit, I really,
really like to build fun things with LEDs,
but I didn't know that I like to build fun
things with LEDs until recently.
I've built like this — this is one of my
dogs.
Despite his cool demeanour, he is actually,
like, very pumped when he gets his Rainbow
collar on because he gets a the lot of attention.
So, like I said, I haven't been working with
Harbour that long, only — I didn't get into
Harvard because I had a practical problem
to solve, I — for my free time, that doesn't
really appeal to me.
I like impractical things, and just doing
things for fun.
I got inspired when I visited an art museum
in Amsterdam, so this is the contemporary
art museum in Amsterdam, and I went to see
an art exhibit by an artist called John Tingly.
He's a Swiss artist from the 1960s and 1970s,
and, for him, art is not about standing in
a sterile, white space and distantly gazing
as a silent painting.
Art is meant to be playful.
He created these installations meant to be
triggered by a viewer.
It was meant to incorporate the viewer's experience
into the overall effects of the work of art,
and it was meant to intentionally blur the
line between artists and viewer, so, he made
several art installations like this where
you could pick a rotting utensil, or a pen,
put it into the art piece, and you trigger
it, and it would create a new work of art
itself.
It was no longer about just watching a process,
by choosing a drawing tool, the viewer plays
a crucial role in the creation of an entirely
new piece of art.
When I was at the exhibit, this quote by him
stood out to me.
It said, "I wanted something ephemeral that
would pass like a falling star.
It had to transpire, make people dream and
talk, and this would be all."
I really liked this idea of art as this temporary
experience that connects artist and viewer,
and it creates this intimate moment between
strangers.
It is just spontaneous.
It is only meant to bring joy and inspire,
and it only lasts a short amount of time.
That got me thinking.
I was very excited by all these ideas and
things I had seen at the art museum, and I
wanted to figure out how I could use my skill
set as a developer and make my own interactive
art experience.
But unlike John, I'm not an established artist.
I didn't have access to a studio space, I
live in a really tiny studio apartment in
Amsterdam, so space is very limited.
I don't have a place to create and exhibit
something.
So, I started thinking about how I could apply
this idea to something that is really accessible,
and for me, that was my clothing.
As you can see, this is my outfit.
This is me out in Amsterdam.
And then, I wanted to make — what was really
important to me was to make a cohesive look.
I didn't want to throw some LEDs on a shirt,
I wanted to create something co-ordinated,
and looked like a complete outfit.
So, as I started out, I was a web developer,
first thought about the web app, would I wanted
to create a web app where users could pick
colours and programmes and send it to my clothes.
The next step which was the stuff that had
the most anxiety for me was actually building
the hard wear into clothing.
I had done some projects by — I had never
done anything like this before.
And picking out the different pieces of hardware,
orchestrating everything together.
Then the last piece of the puzzle would be
sending the negligence from the web app to
the LEDs in my clothing.
For that, I used a library that I'm a huge
fan of called socket IO, used it in my front-end
web development careers.
It is event-based messaging.
It works in every browser on every device.
And it's pretty simple to set up, so I was
confident that my ability to set this up.
So, I had this great plan.
I was super organised.
I thought everything was going to be really,
really easy, but, as you can probably guess,
it wasn't.
Otherwise, I wouldn't have put that slide
in!
I faced a lot of challenges.
At first, I thought most would come from wiring
and soldering because it was just, like, the
most ambitious project I had taken on.
Even though I had setbacks during the project
that frustrated my abilities, I thought I
would never get good at soldering, like figuring
this stuff out, I tried not to let the setbacks
keep me down, and really building stuff, whether
it is hardware or software is about building
iteration, improving on what you built.
Let's start from the beginning.
Like I showed in an earlier slide, this is
my road map for my project.
I would just have a web app, and a socket
IO server, and just deploy that using Node
and Express on Heroku, and then my three pieces
of clothing, buy umbrella, necklace, and skirt,
and those would be socket IO clients.
My main focus, I wasn't concentrating too
much on the software, so I won't speak about
that now but focus on the hardware because
that was my biggest obstacle.
Hardware: I needed to figure out how I was
going to control the LEDs in my clothing.
I had a couple of requirements.
So it needed to be small.
It needed to be discreet, not be bulky.
I needed it to be durable.
Since this is clothing, I'm going to take
it on and off.
I wanted it to last so I could wear it many,
many times.
And my last criteria was I needed Wi-Fi connectivity
because this is how I envisioned that I would
be able to connect the hardware to receive
messages, so I was tethering off my phone's
Wi-Fi hot spot.
So in my case, I chose an Adrino because microcontrollers
are really great for projects like this.
If you're not familiar, the difference between
Adrino and Raspberry Pi, Adrino just runs
a loop, and it's really great when you want
a programme to run, and it can be intermittently
interrupted and update its states, and do
that, but it is just continually running a
loop and listening.
So I chose the Adrino.
It is small, it has Wi-Fi built in, and a
big reason was people love this microprocessor
that uses the ESP8266, so there are lots of
tutorials and information.
So I just felt pretty confident there was
a lot of information where I could figure
things out on it.
I started on the building phase.
If you've never worked on the hardware, you
might be curious what that looks like.
This is what it looks like.
It is not very glamorous in my case.
Like I said, I have a tiny apartment in Amsterdam,
so I don't really have a work space.
It was mainly me sitting on a yoga mat on
the floor just soldering and testing and repeating
the process for just each of these pieces.
When I was ready to go out in public with
this, I tried to think things through.
I didn't want to give people I was interacting
with too much context, so I made up these
cards that I could hand without giving context
to speak a lot to them where they could go
to the web app and interact with it themselves.
So I took it out.
I took it out.
In Amsterdam, we have a lighted bike ride,
people slap Christmas lights and things on
their bikes, so it is a lot of fun.
I decided to take it out.
I want to show you a video clip of what happened
when I took it out.
As you can see, everything's running really
good, and then my skirt goes green, and it's
going green, and it rebooted itself, you can
see it's on a different programme to the rest
of my outfit.
My skirt kept crashing.
[Laughter].
For the people that are around me that weren't
in tech, they were just mesmerised that this
was happening and I could control it.
All I could see was oh, crap, my skirt or
umbrella kept crashing.
It was really embarrassing.
I thought I had built this really durable
thing but it was actually pretty fragile.
I was embarrassed and disappointed.
I went on to iteration 2, or, how I tried
to make it crash less.
With this particular Adrino that I'm using,
when you plug it into your computer, you get
a monitor, so you can do statements like you
do in JavaScript, like console.log statements,
and, as a JavaScript developer, that's how
a lot of times I can quickly debug things.
As you can see from this sample of the log
statements is that it kept disconnecting,
and reconnecting over and over again.
So, the Adrino was having trouble keeping
a steady connection with my socket eye you
server.
I took a step back, and even though I'm a
huge fan of socket IO, it is made for web
applications communicating over HTTP, and
it's geared for browsers, so maybe I didn't
need that for an IoT project.
Just because the library is available, even
if it is a library that you really enjoy,
even if someone has created another version
of that for your tech that you are using,
it might not be the best solution.
So I really just took a step back here, and
thought about, again, what I was up against
when I'm quoting coding for hardware.
When you're coding for hardware, your resources
are really at a premium.
There's just only so much memory and ram that
you're allocated on these tiny, tiny microcontrollers,
and, since I wasn't communicating between
a browser and a server for my hardware, maybe
I didn't need that extra overhead for HTTP,
and I really just needed to find the bare
minimum but still easy to implement and understand
messaging library possible.
That's when I found out about MQTT.
MQTT is a machine-to-machine IoT protocol.
It is what Facebook uses for Facebook messenger
to deliver in-sink messages.
It has been around for a while, invented in
1999 when engineers needed a solution that
would allow for minimal battery loss, and
minimal bandwidth when connect ing sensors
from remote areas in Africa over a shoddy
satellite connection.
I really could give a whole talk about how
amazing MQTT is, but I just want to highlight
some of the things that really appealed to
me and made we want to do the switch.
So, it's based on a published subscribe architecture,
so there are clients that you can integrate
like in my web app, and the clothing, and
there's a broker.
Client connect to the broker.
That mediates the communication.
What is a key parking of this architecture
is that, when a device connects, it can subscribe
to topics.
When another another client puts in a message
that was that topic, that has that topic,
it subscribes to it.
I like this architecture because the publisher
and the subscribers don't need to know about
each other.
They don't have to run at the same time, and
operations on both components are not halted
during the publishing or receiving of messages.
It's super, super lightweight, so it's transported
over TCP/IP, it only has a two-byte overhead,
and they meant to keep it this way, keep these
package headers really small, and every bit
in that packet is just carefully crafted to
reduce the amount of data transmitted over
the networks.
It means that in comparison to other protocols
like HTTP, it doesn't load the network with
transfer of information, that's just necessary
to allow the protocol to run.
And then, having this small overhead, it's
really ideal for IoT because it lowers the
amount of data that might be transmitted over
really constrained networks.
And another thing I really like is the MQTT
has a really short and readable spec, and
it uses simple verbs to describe actions.
Basically, there are five verbs in MQTT: connect,
disconnect, publish, subscribe, and ping.
So I was really jazzed up about MQTT and I
couldn't wait to switch out my socket IO client
and server and mews MQTT instead.
I started with the web app.
There is mqtt.js library, and you can Lewis
it in the line ry.
It is written in the JavaScript, and you can
use it in Node and in the browser.
I think the code is pretty easy to follow,
and that's one reason I really liked implementing
this because it is only really a few lines.
I require the library, and then I create a
client that connects to the URL wherever in
the internet I have my broker created, and
then, in this example, if I have a Rainbow
button to change my clothes, so I just create
a function, so, whenever that button is clicked,
it sends a message to the broker with the
topic lights, so that is what I have my outfit
clients subscribe to, and it can send a payload
string of Rainbow.
Next set up a client on Adrino.
Even if you're not familiar with Adrino C++
code, it's pretty much the same as the other
client.
Just include the library, I tell it where
the broker is located, which on the web, where
to find it, and it subscribes to the topic
lights, and then, whenever a message is received,
just this message method is called, and then
it can just interpret the messages sent, and
then figure out what programme it needs to
switch to.
So I had my clients set up.
It was all going like pretty smoothly, and
the next, I needed to set up the broker so
everything could talk to each other.
And I just want to show this slide again.
Like I said before, I deployed everything
just on one express server on Heroku.
When I went to set up my brother, even though
I love Heroku, I found out you don't have
port access.
You can't specify specific ports, and for
this MQTT protocol, the port that specified
you need to use for communication is 1883,
so that was a slight hiccup because I couldn't
build my own MQTT broker.
I didn't have access to the port, I couldn't
set this up but I was not ready to leave Heroku.
I wanted to see if all this stuff was going
to actually work together well before I actually
moved to a different service.
So I went looking for an external MQTT broker
service, and it turns out there is a bunch
of them.
The one I ended up choosing is called Shifter
IO, an IoT prototyping platform, I chose it
because it is free.
You just give your email and you get a key
and a token.
Compared to other broker services, it doesn't
seem to limit the number of messages that
you can receive per minute.
Some do, and you have to peel pay if you receive
more than a few messages a minute.
I tried it out, and it worked.
It worked really, really well compared to
my first attempt.
I was happy but I wasn't ecstatic.
Here I was, relying on this small external
broker service which wasn't optimal for me
because there are a lot of unknowns.
I didn't know that much about this company
and I wanted to make something really reliable,
and I really felt to make it really reliable,
I needed to have control over it.
As you can probably guess, the next thing
I decided to do was create my own broker.
To do that, I had to move from Heroku to Digital
Ocean which gave me a little bit of anxiety
because I've not that comfortable or skilled
yet in doing like DevOps-y kind of stuff,
but it worked out.
You should not be scared of that if you're
thinking about moving to a service like that.
So, to build this, I used this broker library
called Yates.
What I really — 80s.
What I liked this, was using streams, and
just, it's a really new modern library, is
that the broker is embeddable.
It would be embeddable in my current express
server that I was using to serve my website,
so I would really have minimal configuration
change.
I was happy I wouldn't have to build a second
server just for handling this messaging.
So, so implement the MQTT broker, I include
the library and create the MQTT server and
the HTTP server, because as I said, this was
also serving my web app.
I specified the ports they needed to listen
on to.
Then, at the bottom, you can see that, with
, and I think this is really cool as well,
I can add on so that the HTTP serve er that
is serving my website, it can have MQTT over
WebSocket capabilities, so, those messages
coming from my web app, they are served using
WebSockets from the HTTP server.
I was pretty excited because this was working
really good, and I had figured out a lot of
things, and I conquered DevOps' fears, so
I was pretty excited.
The last thing I did, because I wanted to
make this rock solid, which, I hope in a you
phenomena minutes that I show that it is rock
solid, is that I upgraded the microcontroller.
So I decided to change to the Feather M0 Wi-Fi,
and there are a couple of of reasons for that.
It has low power management, so I wanted to
stretch out as much out of my battery life
as I could, and the main reason was that it
has a separate Wi-Fi module, so what that
means is that it doesn't have to yield all
the time to the Wi-Fi core since it is a separate
chip, so you get full rein of the processor
in timing, and it just means you have high-speed
reliable Wi-Fi that doesn't crash.
There is a downside, and that is that it is
twice the cost of the other microcontroller
I was using, so the Feather is around 18 euros,
and this cost 35.
That was downside that wasn't — it was worth
the extra cost to get the reliability.
It is demo time.
This is probably the biggest audience I have
had who can interact with this.
I invite you to go to flashylights.nl and
you can change what it looks like.
This is meant to be a one-on-one experience
so it might get glitchy with so many people
sending to it at the same time.
Let's go for it!
While you're playing around, I want to leave
you with my closing thoughts that you might
not be aware that I'm a super introvert, and
this was a really experiment to do as an introvert.
I'm not one that attracting attention and
actively seeking people to interact with me,
it's completely out of my comfort zone.
Sorry!
But it was also an experiment that really
pushed me to deal with my own reactions to
those inter action, and I wanted to see if
I could bring a momentary joy and whimsy to
strangers by giving them free rein over my
appearance.
Outside of our tech bubble, this is not an
application, this is an application, like
this is not one that most people have seen
and experienced, so it is really — I also
found that I was breaking stereotypes about
tech with strangers, like they were kind of
taken aback when they realised that I had
built this, and you could do these kind of
weird experiments with tech, and kind of questioned
what you could build, and who was capable
of billing those things in tech.
That's it.
Thank you for listening!
[Applause].
[Cheering].
I also build other fun things with LEDs, so,
if you're interested in seeing those, I'm
terrible at blogging at things, but I post
pictures on Twitter, and later tonight, I
made another that is not interactive but still
really, really cool that I want to wear tonight
at the party, so, if you see me, say hi, don't
be shy.
Thank you.
[Cheering].
[Applause]